à la charité sur loire cette entreprise
fabrique des maisons au kit à ossature
bois en un an et demi elle est passé de
90 à 130 salariés
une croissance qui s'accompagne de
nombreux projets le dispositif
territoire d'industrie pourrait
d'ailleurs permettre d'accélérer la
réalisation d'une nouvelle ligne de
production
une innovation et surtout un process qui
a déjà défini une industrialisation à
l'investissement est surtout la phase de
recrutement parce que ça va être
demandeur d'emploi et on a vu que le
territoire d'industrie en fait un axe
beaucoup sur le problème de recrutement
et la formation le recrutement c'est
également l'une des préoccupations du
technicentre de la sncf
le site compte près de 800 emplois
industriels et 38 ans gauche ou encore
prévue en 2019 des démarches pour
lesquels un accompagnement sera proposé
on a des besoins identifiés pour les
années à venir pour les trois ans qui
arrive notre chargé principalement en
augmentation donc on va avoir besoin
d'opérateurs de techniciens d'ingénieurs
les territoires l'industrie va nous
ouvrir les portes sur cet aspect aussi
innovation dans les ressources et le
nouveau territoire d'industrie nevers
val de loire doit servir d'accélérateur
chaque communauté de communes proposera
des projets pour lesquels l'état a
promis 1 3 milliard d'euros sur le plan
national qui s'ajouteront à des
financements régionaux
l'industrie fait partie des les choses
que l'on veut absolument conserver sur
nos territoires
ça nous permet de le développer à
travers cette industrie justement à nous
d'aller chercher ce qu'on peut trouver
sur cette enveloppe dédiée à ces
territoires d'industrie qui n'ont pas
été choisis par hasard ils ont été
choisis pour leur tissu industriel ça
veut dire que nous en avons un
le contrat devrait être signé en juin
prochain et ses effets sont espérées par
les professionnels dans la nièvre 12,9
pour cent des emplois dépendent
directement de l'industrie